et on reste au mali retrouvez notre
invité boubacar bâ bonjour et merci de
répondre à nos questions sur france 24
vous êtes chercheur au centre d analyse
sur la gouvernance et la sécurité au
sahel on vous doit notamment le livre
crise de gouvernance justice
transitionnelle et paix durable au mali
ces paris aux éditions la sahélienne la
fin de l'opération barkan se dessine
donc au mali est ce que la france au
fonds a eu le choix la junte lui a
montré clairement la sortie
il ya deux possibilités
c'est une question de lecture un jeu
politique
la gêne est consenti à une question de
souveraineté et d'exigence de l'opinion
publique après les événements de 2020
2021 et puis l'organisation des assises
nationales pour la réfondation de
l'autre côté la france pense qu'elle
s'est investi la version centre du mali
non car ce type nous avons des positions
qui se sont retrouvés en face avec une
crise diplomatique d'encore il faut une
lecture beaucoup plus
précise mais en tenant compte de deux
opinions publiques françaises et
maliennes quand vous dites une exigence
de souveraineté vous voulez dire quoi au
fond et vous savez que depuis 2012 avec
la crise malienne lafontaine agi
honnêtement avec les événements de 2013
avec la libération d'une campagne du
nord ce qui s'est passé à quoi donc
l'intervention des servals le premier
couac c'est le fait que l'armée malienne
n'a pas pu accéder à kidal ça c'est en
2013 donc c'est un acte et peu de
défiance par rapport à la structure
militaire 2007 deuxièmement on est passé
de cerval apte à kouba et pardon à dakar
et à des coups bas donc il ya eu des
mutations sein des concertations claire
par rapport aux bannis donc le mali est
proche un peu la france dans son
évolution
transformationnel militaires des étapes
qui n'ont pas été clairement identifiée
est vraiment analyser en pur et
troisièmement il me semble aussi que le
vent lui repprocher la france aussi
d'engager takouba d'engager les robes
sont des clarifications au niveau de
l'accord de défense donc il ya deux
accords de défense et l accord de
coopération militaire et un accord de
défense
par rapport à l'intervention de la
france donc il y de quiproquos alors que
du côté français la france parce que en
2013 lorsque hollande s'est présenté au
mali il a dit que c'est le plus beau
jour de ma vie c'est une nouvelle
alliance entre le matin donc avec ses
seize éléments cités du côté manière la
france pense qu'elle doit repositionner
parce que le coup d'état militaire au
mahdi n'est pas normal le deuxième coup
d'état a encore enfoncé le pays et la
france se trouvait dans une position de
réponse seulement par rapport au sahel
donc là vous voyez deux visions
différentes deux options différentes et
la russe a réussi le temps on va en
parler de la rue si vous parlez de
quiproquos boubacar bah on est passé
finalement des quiproquos à la suspicion
puisque la france est accusée
aujourd'hui par le premier ministre
malien de soutenir certains groupes
armés est ce que la france n'est pas
victime aussi puisque cette information
est fausse et ce que la france n'est pas
aussi victime de désinformation
bon la désinformation vous voyez
aujourd'hui c'est le problème est plus
complexe
elle est aussi dangereuse qu'est
laquelle la désinformation et la
manipulation mais disent dégoûtés il ya
deux événements diplomatiques important
d'un goûter en 2020 la france a engagé
le processus à kouba et il m'a dit pense
que dans ce processus il ya pas eu de
concertation ses profondes donc la
déclaration du président français des
changements de posture a influencé le
côté malien et du côté manière le prix
ministre a annoncé bien sûr
lors de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies que le mahdi a été abandonné après
un bac es à une riposte du côté du
président français en disant qu il fait
une transition illégitime et qui ne
répondent pas à certaines valeurs
démocratiques donc il y avait ce
quiproquo et là nous sommes arrivés à
une troisième phase l'interprétation des
accords vous voyez ce niveau
il ya quand même des difficultés des
perceptions de la gouvernance et de la
vision militaire et là dessus ça s'est
exacerbée aujourd'hui nous sommes à un
moment crucial avec cette rencontre de
l'elysée ce soir et demain l'union
européenne et américaine service qui est
l'avenir du barca doit être ré
dimensionner les l'attention des
conséquences sont complexes quel va être
le rôle de la mairie aujourd'hui c'est à
cannes quel va être le rôle de
l'héritière et deux des quatre scènes
dont vous voyez un peu la couverture de
la france pour la protection de ses
actuels aussi importante du côté malien
le mali va diversifier et là c'est une
question de souveraineté le mali va
diversifier et quel va être le rôle
aujourd'hui des acteurs émergents comme
la russie comme la turquie comme l'iran
et compte d'autres et l'algérie aussi
qui a un rôle important donc quand vous
prenez encore tout ça nous sommes dans
une sorte de confidentialité des zones
aujourd'hui du nord du centre et je
pense qu'il ya deux ou trois mois les
groupes étaient aux abords de bamako
deux côtés est et deux côtés précisent
les bamakois alors on fait quelques
kilomètres aujourd'hui avec
l'intervention de la russie et
l'intervention aérien et puis militaires
il ya quand même un retrait de ce groupe
et je pense que le made in et dans une
autre posture de cette guerre
donc la russie selon vous pourrait aider
à faire reculer les groupes jihadistes
finalement on a du mal à comprendre en
tout cas vu de paris la mission de ces
miliciens wagner est ce que c'est de
lutter contre les djihadistes ou est ce
que c'est de protéger la junte
d'abord est-ce qu'on a la preuve que les
munitions avec merck sont là au mali on
en parle mais voilà pas de pleurer elle
mais c'est qu'il y assez qu il ya des
photos qui sont sortis
oui mais les fautes au sol ne suffisent
pas de toutes les façons il ya une
guerre de l'information et avec la
désinformation même si vous voulez la
faire sans vous de la présence de wagner
au mali je pense que au lieu dit sans en
avoir les preuves pas parlé et il ya
quand même des insultes aurige et
défonce risques sur le terrain dans la
région de meaux qui est ou lors du bâti
ça quand même c'est confirmé
premièrement il va falloir aujourd'hui
qu'elle est langil un jeu pour moi c'est
que depuis l'intervention de la rue si
les groupes jihadistes sont repliés dans
des zones de forêts dans des zones
stratégiques pour accorder prendre sur
le terrain pas symétriques premièrement
deuxièmement nous observons aussi que
l'âme est reparti à l'offensive dans la
zone du cercle de niono c'est à dire la
geôle chez vous dans la région de mopti
est un peu dans la zone de goumois donc
l'armée dans une position offensive et
sur ce terrain et les combats entre les
groupes locaux c'est à dire j'ai gardé
des données massago milices locales et
de la katiba massina se recentrer dans
le gourmand et dans la zone des falaises
donc assez logique il ya quand même un
vrai plus des acteurs jihadistes
maintenant je ne dis pas que le terrain
est finie parce que nous sommes dans une
guerre hybride est asymétrique je pense
que la russie va a pu le mener sur le
terrain et rien que ce le terrain des
renseignements en accompagnant les
forces de défense et de sécurité
cela va changer n'a pas réussi à faire
la france selon vous la france a réussi
d'un goûter à apporter un appui en 2013
pour empêcher les groupes d'avancer vers
le sud du pays censé en 2013 conan
deuxièmement elle a réengagé
l'approchent à partir du parquet en le
clippant du sahel et c'est là où les
contradictions ont commencé parce que
couvre le sahel de couffouleux m'a dit
ça fait deux dimensions donc la france
est confrontée à un problème à mon avis
deux visions des stratèges chaque
gouvernement sept centièmes hollande
avait sa vision mc oran sa vision
aujourd'hui il est difficile de combiner
les deux visions parce que là certaines
français quand vous écoutez qui soit
clément bollée ou quand les couples est
rassurant c'est une approche quelquefois
pneumatiques mais qu'il n'est pas très
compréhensible sur la dimension du sahel
donc à ce titre le mali a besoin de
diversifier en tant qu'etat souverain
c'est pour cela que la russie est venue
nous pensons que si nous analysons la
mode la maison la france parce que il ya
des enjeux il ya des relations du solide
il ya aussi aujourd'hui même la
possibilité de limiter un peu ce secteur
du combat 10 à 10 pour empêcher
d'atteindre l'europe je pense que la
france a des intérêts le mali a des
intérêts il va falloir tourner
convergence des intérêts les russes
aussi ont-ils des intérêts économiques
eux on parle de contrats qui ont été
signés
pour la détention de certains certaines
mines au mali
écoutez il parle raconte mais la réalité
il n'y a pas de preuves de ces contrats
mais quand même la russie ne viendra pas
sur ce terrain que la france parce que
la fête bat allergie à des intérêts la
russie a besoin de redimensionner sa
géopolitique
il est très fort aussi blanc que ce
travail de la russie soient rémunérés
mais nous ne connaissons pas aujourd'hui
cette dimension il ya quand même c'est
que la défense on essaie de spéculer il
ya des rapports aussi des américains sur
la question comme quoi le mal et doit
payer 10 millions par mois de dollars là
en tout cas il va falloir comprendre
parce que je ne pense pas que tout soit
dire sur leur terrain et économique où
le terrain financier il ya aussi des
enjeux stratégiques il allait réussir à
vis de m épi est partout de la france
dans le sahel là c'est vraiment un
contexte de géopolitique et de guerre
froide il va falloir éviter que le mali
soit victime d'un peu de ces engins dans
ce grand acteur ou partie d'une
stratégie politique dans sa bombe à
carbes à une dernière question sur
la la suite maintenant puisqu'on attend
les annonces des manuels macron soit ce
soir soit demain jeudi
il semblerait que la france compte
désormais sur le niger pour accueillir
le gros des troupes est ce que c'est le
bon choix merci vous avez à redresser un
peu mieux est ce que le niger est un
pays assez solide
le niger à la main pour le mali mais les
dimensions gouvernance et d'état sont
pas les mêmes mais ce que je note c'est
que le niger à ses intérêts et il est
partout surtout aux intérêts miniers la
france est très très appliqué au niger
par rapport à l'exportation de grandes
longue mais la position du niger avec
des déclarations du musée fêtera gère à
fragiliser les relations entre le niger
et le mali donc il est possible que back
and et puis d'un coup bas sur les
positions au niger mais attention les
groupes armés sur tous les goûts
d'inspection des djihadistes qu'il soit
2 nîmes ou bien de les gestes ont la
capacité de faire des mouvements entre
les trois pays donc que le mali le niger
le burkina donc il est fort possible que
c'est la france 2 des pauvres légère
qu'il a gouverné changent de tactique et
redéploie vers le niger donc le mari
aura une route position mais est ce que
cela veut dire que de mal hier mais tout
dépendra un peu aussi la façon dont les
forces maliennes vont s'engager sur le
terrain est engagé je dis bien et la
tactique je dis bien de chercher ce
groupe et les amener dans cette position
et je ne sais pas si le niger a les
moyens aujourd'hui même malgré l'aide de
la france de pouvoir les contenir dans
la zone du goût moi donc j'ai beaucoup
de réserve et beaucoup de retenue par
rapport la question attendons encore
quelques mois pour moi comment la
géopolitique d'israël va se résigner
après le départ de matane qui est
inéluctable parce que le made in
aujourd'hui est confronté à des
questions exigence de souveraineté de
son peuple et aujourd'hui il ya deux
mois ce groupe était aux abords de
monaco et l'as l'offensive a permis de
les réguler il va falloir attendre
comment la stratégie va se dérouler sur
le terrain merci boubacar à nous avoir
donné votre point de vue sur france 24
je rappelle le titre de votre ouvrage
crise de gouvernance justice
transitionnelle et paix durable au mali
aux éditions la sahélienne vous
interveniez depuis bamako